عدم توسيع رقعه الحرب ذلك هو عنوان الجوله
الجديده لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني
بلينكن التي شملت تركيا والاردن وقطر
والسعوديه والامارات بلينكن ذكر ان كل
قاده المنطقه كانوا مجمعين على ضروره عدم
ترك الحرب تتوسع وهذه افاده ناقصه فقاده
المنطقه طالبوا ايضا بوقف العدوان
الاسرائيلي على غزه الذي ادى الى مقتل
اكثر من 23 الف فلسطيني ثلثا هذا العدد من
النساء والاطفال وتركت الحرب الجاريه الاف
اخرين تحت الانقاض وادت الى اصابه نحو 60
الف شخص فهل المطلوب التحوط من توسع الحرب
ام وقفها بعد مجازر وصفتها اكثر من جهه
حقوقيه بانها ترقى الى كونها اباده جماعيه
لشعب وفي شان ترتيب الا الاولويات في غزه
من وجهه النظر الامريكيه حرص بلينكن في
جولته على ضمان الحصول على تعهدات من
الدول التي زارها بالمساهمه في عمليات
اعاده اعمار القطاع والانخراط في طبيعه
مهام اليوم التالي لوقف الحرب في غزه ومره
اخرى يبدو هذا الامر استباقا لمطلوب
المهمه الاكثر الحاحا كما يراها
الفلسطينيون ودول المنطقه وهي وقف سفك
الدم الفلسطيني وانهاء ماسات التي اريد
للعالم ان يتصالح مع رؤيتها ويتعايش مع
مشاهد قتل الحياه الانسانيه في اكبر عرض
تلفزيوني للفضا ولبشا ما عرفت البشريه في
تاريخها مثيلا
له وكان بلينكن قد عبر عن تعاطف انساني
وتاثر بالغين للفواق العظيمه لمراسل
الجزيره وائل الدحدوح الذي استشهد معظم
افراد اسرته زوجته وولداه وبنته وحفيده
واصفا ذلك بالماسه غير المحتمله ولو اراد
بلينكن التوسع في النظر وفي الحكم لكان
راى غزه كلها وائل الدحدوح فقصه وائل هي
قصه الفلسطيني المستباح دمه منذ عام
48 هي قصته ايضا في الصمود وفي التسامي
فوق جراحه وحزنه في رحله شعبه الدامي نحو
حريته يحمل الوزير بلينكن الى اسرائيل
رجاءات اكثر منها طلبات فالولايات المتحده
من وجهه نظر الفلسطينيين ضال في الحرب
طلوع اسرائيل فيها سيطلب بلنك من اسرائيل
تقليل كثافه عملياتها العسكريه والاكتفاء
بعمليات النوعيه وفي الواقع ذلك ما استقرت
عليه القياده العسكريه الاسرائيليه بعدما
فشلت في تحرير اي اسير وبعد ما وجدت من
استشا العالم جرائمها ما ادخلها في عزله
سينقل بلينكن الى رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو الموقف الامريكي المخير
بين النزول على رجاءات واشنطن وبين الذهاب
مذهب وزيه المتطرفين وزير الامن القومي بن
غفير ووزير الماليه سموتريتش
والوزير كلاهما يدعوان الى ضروره دفع
الفلسطينيين الى هجره الطوعيه الى مختلف
دول العالم بل تتعالى وسط اليمين الصهيوني
اصواتهم واصوات غيرهم تدعو الى احتلال
القطاع وانشاء مستوطنات فيه والى انشاء
مستوطنات في نابلس وتكرم في الضفه الغربيه
الاحتلال ثم الاستيطان انها القصه
الاسرائيليه منذ عام
8 كان خلاص اليهودي لا يتحقق الا باستعاده
ماساته عبر الفلسطيني الذي يجب ان يقتل
كما قتلوا ويتبعثر في الدنيا كما تبعثر
اسرائيل تريد للفلسطيني ان يكون انعكاسا
لتاريخ اليهودي الناجي من المذابح المشرد
في
الافاق يجب انلا تتوسع رقعه الحرب يقول
بلينكن وعدم توسعها يعني حبس حريقها حيث
هي في غزه غير ان الحرب التي تدخل شهرها
الرابع تشق المجتمع الاسرائيلي وتخلخل
تماسك قيادته السياسيه والعسكريه فرئيس
الوزراء نتنياهو ووزير دفاعه جلنت يرفضان
وقف الحرب لان وقفها سيعني محاسبته على كل
اخفاق عسكري منذ طوفان الاقصى في السابع
من اكتوبر الماضي ووقف الحرب سيعني
لنتنياهو فتح ملفات فساده امام المحاكم
اما الاستمرار في الحرب فسيعني مزيدا من
الاخفاق العسكري وهو اتهام يبلغ به زعيم
المعارضه الاسرائيليه يائير لابيد حد
مطالبه نتنياهو بالاستقاله لعجزه عن اداره
الدوله وقياده
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الحرب اما معضله الخطاب الامريكي ازاء
الحرب حتى الان فهي معالجته جوهر الصراع
بمقاربات تكتيكيه تتحدث عن اعاده البناء
في غزه وحصر نطاق الحرب
[تصفيق]
فيها لكن الحرب الاسرائيليه التي تشن على
غزه تحت عنوان القضاء على حماس هي في
الواقع حرب على الشعب الفلسطيني كله وعلى
مشروعه الوطني الممتد من غزه الى الضفه
الغربيه الى القدس هكذا ترى المقاومه
الفلسطينيه الحربه وهي تربك حسابات
اسرائيل كل يوم ما يضرها من قعد عنها ما
دامت هي واقفه
وقفتها
الشماء